so when Seattle raised the minimum wage
a study found that it caused a $1,500
grant
drop in yearly income for lower wage
workers but the wage increase doesn't
just nail the wallet it goes after your
butt yep if you're currently in a
Seattle bathroom suffering from an acute
bout of Montezuma's Revenge
after eating chili cheese fries at your
local grease pit you can thank that
minimum wage increase for your
disgusting discomfort follow my logic
another new study found that for every
dollar increase in the minimum wage
there's a 6 percent jump in health code
violations
hence the trots Dana I could tell you
were puzzled
so when businesses get hit with a
financial burden they not only cut
workers in hours they cut corners and
maybe in hygiene poor cleanliness as you
can see by my chart that I drew can
migrate to your plate which then goes to
your stomach and then down to the
bathroom where you end up counting the
tiles till midnight it's a science
you can thank short-sighted liberals for
this and of course the solution will be
more government as officials find the
restaurants until they close up further
proving that the only true radicals left
are small business owners who chase
dreams despite obstacles foisted upon
them by useless bureaucrats who've never
run a damn thing in their lives
forget Daredevils their risks are
minimal compared to the guy or gal
trying to start something up and keep it
going thanks to the punitive big
government it gets flushed down the
toilet I will be auctioning this
wonderful piece of artwork later if
you're so interested wan what do you
make of my theory as tenuous as it might
be that the minimum wage gives you
diarrhea raising the minimum given that
I know you and I know your feeling about
Chipotle yeah the problems that they've
had yes is that it did they raise the
minimum wage yeah there could be a
correlation I didn't I don't
I've had a few hoop skirmishes with
their men's room
yeah good intentions never deliver good
results liberals don't understand
capitalism and human nature same thing
happened with Obamacare when you mandate
that these small businesses have to
cover health care for their employees
they just cut them to part-time then
they have less money and still no health
care they slapped a yacht tax in Florida
on all these yachts to soak the rich
what happens people buy yachts in other
states and then these middle-class
workers that are making all these yachts
are out of work because no one's doing
business in Florida anymore
same thing with gun-free zones guns are
dangerous so liberals create gun-free
zones and then that's where all the mass
shootings happen
liberals never learn from their mistakes
it's like socialism doesn't work in the
Soviet Union Venezuela Cuba but they
keep trying to replicate it here for the
rich and gun owners of a rich gun owners
that's your people Kimberly it's just
liberals get in the end always will get
you and your stomach but see the problem
is a little bit of fake news can you
blame everything on Capote ley and
minimum wage increases but you actually
have legitimate diagnosed
gastrointestinal I have just you know I
just have a I have a sensitive stomach
this is an embarrassing you met oh I
just know so much about it but no you
don't have to say this in front of by
the way that picture will make a lot of
money for charity yes how many toys in
your bathroom 64 people rest their case
I think you know we're gonna do a part
two of this segment coming up where
we're gonna delve deeper into these this
gastrointestinal part two part number
two let's take cash
we're number one and number two